[Music]
my name is Madeline and I'm a dancer and
a cog refer and I come here from malmö
Sweden I'm just gonna start spacer
[Music]
actually came across contemporary dance
2012 and it was through my previous job
actually I'm a social worker and project
where I was working with young girls
women with disability and 2000 as well
go to Steph's feature write me and asked
do you have someone in your group that
would love to try contemporary dance and
I say yeah we're like a pastor question
and see and there was two girls women
today that they wanted to try and I also
felt but I needed to be a little bit of
a role model for the others so I also
stepped in to try and that was actually
the first time ever I've tried
[Applause]
[Music]
uncharted is a part of European access
we are basically going to choose free
spots in malmö we're basically going to
deep deep into these spaces and create
quality with these spaces so it will be
a challenge of who we normally see in
these spaces to challenge inspected
bodies in in unexpected places so it
will be three spots and three different
copies
it is something special
using your body as a tool in your work
also you mind an imagination but
especially for me it's with my body I
have always been quite physical I have
done a lot of sports before so I've
always liked pushing myself physically
and something I discovered here in
contemporary does that you also you're
also really pushing your mind somehow
especially in the creative process and
that is something that I really like to
constantly step over this comfort zones
also my physical barriers so there's a
lot of things that in an individual
personal way in advance that makes me
grow
so that's why I really love it and I
obviously also because there's a lot of
meeting with people in this in this work
[Music]
[Applause]
you